you used to be they never had chairs
that anybody can remember in front of
the desk but I've always done it this
way where I'm at the desk and I have
people here but usually they would sit
on the sofas but this is the resolute
desk it's a great desk with a phenomenal
history many great presidents were
behind this desk and then some choose
other desks they have about seven desks
that you can actually choose but I like
this this was FDR was Ronald Reagan it
was Kennedy that's some great presidents
Wow that's something John and you're
standing there talking to the president
United States in the Oval Office I don't
care who you are it to me it never feels
blase to come to the White House and be
inside this building and all that it
represents to the country and that's the
that believe that's the resolute is the
desk with the famous picture of John
Kennedy and Little John Candy the door
underneath climbing through it so yeah
it's a it's an amazing thing the video I
know a lot of people who would come to
the White House in the present age have
said this to me and they would say to
this president I'm gonna go and tell the
president what I think and then when
they would come out the parade would go
to see them and say how did it go and
they would say he's a great president
right George W Bush is to tell that
story about his father people would say
I'm gonna go give him what for and
they'd walk in and say that's a nice
time as compressor and it's game yeah
there's a magical thing that happens
once you cross that person you're like
homina homina homina yes
after the oklahoma's conversation john
travel aboard Air Force One with the
president of Pennsylvania while their
president Trump signed his 32nd
executive order mr. Trump also met with
workers at a tool Factory and spoke at a
rally to mark his 100th day in office
and at the factory I asked the president
about his next SEC set of priorities and
how he plans to work with Congress what
about infrastructure when is that going
to have to do infrastructure very
quickly we've got the plan largely
completed and we'll be filing it over
the net
three weeks maybe soon you said you were
disappointed in the Republicans in
Congress why well disappointed they're
friends of mine they're really special
people whether it's freedom caucus or or
Tuesday or Thursday or let's go have a
drink
that group they're great people I know
em all and I can honestly say we get a
lot of them I can honestly say I don't
dislike any of them I like almost all of
them a lot and you know we have some
votes that have never voted positively
but now we're the governing party before
it didn't matter they could vote no one
wouldn't matter because President Obama
was going to be to everything and they
didn't have the Senate now we have the
Senate the house of the White House but
these are great people and I think
you're going to see the Republican Party
really come together so they're kind of
learning what it's like to be in charge
well the governing now they never
governed you know they haven't governed
now their governing so now it's just not
like saying no before they could say no
it didn't matter because it wasn't going
to get approved in ago so what different
issues the makers
now we're governing and I'll tell you
what Republican Party they're great
people and frankly a lot of the
Democrats are great they have bad
leadership Schumer is not a leader this
is not how to lead I known for a long
time he has no leadership ability and
he's bringing them so far left they're
never going to win another election
believe me what's the difference between
negotiating in Washington versus
negotiating in business well I think the
big difference is for what we're doing
here Washington you really need heart
because you're talking about a lot of
people whereas business you don't need
so much heart right you want to make a
good deal Wow really interests I won't
say that about that tell us about all
the workers that were standing there
they were dying to just touch him to I
mean he is he is their champion and
that's why he was in that factory it
charges him back up those are the people
he's fighting for and this is the
dynamic we've been covering ever since
he was in the campaign which is they are
they see him in there fighting and you
know if he's having any difficulties at
all it doesn't matter to them because
he's swinging for them in a way they
don't think anybody in Washington has
been working for them and you just saw
it in the interactions between them
right they wanted leadership they wanted
leadership and they also want somebody
who wakes up in the morning thinking
about them and it sends a message to
them and that's the bond that that he
has with his voters which is that they
they think there is a person in
Washington pushing back against the city
that's not been working for them and
working on their behalf and that is a
that's an emotional connection it has
nothing to do with tax rates and I mean
it may eventually but that emotion was
really on displays and you know the poll
showed 96 percent of the people that
voted for him do not regret that vote
you see it in the smiles of those men
standing there it's right they believe
he's on their side thank you very much
Sean